Dear in a few days
On October 15,
we have an incredible opportunity.
to drive a powerful wedge in the arrangement between the
The Left Platform and PSL
wedge
stuck in the system that has ruled Nami for several decades
which will lead to
dissection of this system
Only the Confederation
as a fresh force in the political market
is able to do it
high time
to send the old
Detached from the reality of grandparents
whose role is
Pushing the Right Button at the Right Time
for political retirement
Let's finally get it over with
to be decided by people
who moments before the introduction of any regulations
Maybe they met with some lobbyists.
There are a lot of such people in the
im
Does not care about our interest
They will sell us for a few dollars or something.
a luxury trip
and it's high time
these people from the Sejm chase
Some say
and the confederation grows
Their ideas are unrealistic.
We are the only ones who really want to move.
System of State Functioning
Reform it in some way.
We don't care about that
to put money everywhere
where to get this money
we don't work that way
that a here is added
here is printed
here he borrows
and here the most expenses will move
Dear Ladies
You know well
No woman with a farm budget
Home
And we know that in most cases it is.
that the woman in the house rules the money
No woman works that way.
How the Polish state works now
Because every woman knows
that such action
Sooner or later it will lead to this
that these debts will go to children
Only politicians don't understand.
they don't understand it
because they live all the time
from state money
And they do what they want with that money.
spending them on their
the boldest wildest fantasies
and we will not allow it
pay attention
that all parties
platform left
or pesel
outdo each other in the distribution of our money
Only the Confederation
He goes out to all these parties and says,
pretty enough
Fucking up our money
which as taxpayers we pay into the budget
Enough
imposing high taxes and high marches on us
that you politicians
They could have wasted that money.
we speak clearly
we want to list them all in the Sejm
but we won't do it right away
to be clear
Confederation is a long-term project
I currently think
We have about 12% support.
but pay attention
This is twice as much as in 2019.
This is a signal for you.
We are a political investment
with a high rate of return
a in the case of potential early elections
I guarantee you
that we will go even higher
See what confusion
made our 11 members and now imagine
What will happen in the Diet
If we enter 40
50 members
we will be the hottest breath on their political neck
almost burning blast
and for you
we will be a great freshness in the Polish parliament
That is why they are afraid of us.
That is why they attack us
because they want to keep their Kwon status
who earn gigantic fortunes by imposing
huge taxes and margins on US
they have us somewhere
Only our money matters to them
We want to live normally
we want to earn with dignity thanks to our skills
our cleverness
our entrepreneurship and our diligence
because Poland is to be rich with the wealth of its citizens
Not foreign corporations
and fat teddy bears from the village
As Mr.
Janusz said yes
I know he said a lot of things
but he succeeded
the world is made by young and energetic people
10 Weaknesses
holds the eagle by its feet and does not allow it to fly
This is exactly what socialism is all about.
man wants to do something and from the neck has
pizzanekit 2 tax offices
and he can't fly
The program is simple.
Must open the window
and let people fly
Let people act
and confederation
love is this window
we have little time
There are only a few days left until October 15.
In these few days we have to
Convince as many people as possible
Vote for List 5
so let's not waste time let's act
I greet you cmok